THE HOUR.
RIGHT NOW, HERE’S THE PRESIDENT.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ON THIS GOOD FRIDAY, CHRISTIANS
FROM ALL AROUND THE WORLD
REMEMBER THE SUFFERING AND DEATH
UPON THE CROSS OF OUR LORD AND
SAVIOR, JESUS CHRIST.
AT EASTER SUNDAY, WE WILL
CELEBRATE HIS GLORIOUS
RESURRECTION.
AT THIS HOLY TIME, OUR NATION IS
ENGAGED IN A BATTLE LIKE NEVER
BEFORE, THE INVISIBLE ENEMY.
OUR BRAVE DOCTORS, NURSES, AND
RESPONDERS, FIRST RESPONDERS.
RESPONDERS OF ALL, THEY ARE
FIGHTING TO SAVE LIVES.
OUR WORKERS ARE RACING TO
DELIVER CRITICAL MEDICAL
SUPPLIES.
OUR BEST SCIENTISTS ARE WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK TO DEVELOP
LIFE-SAVING THERAPEUTICS.
I THINK THEY ARE DOING REALLY
WELL IN DOING SO.
OUR PEOPLE ARE MAKING TREMENDOUS
SACRIFICES TO END THIS PANDEMIC.
THOUGH WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
GATHER TOGETHER WITH ONE ANOTHER
AS WE NORMALLY WOULD ON EASTER,
WE CAN USE THIS SACRED TIME TO
FOCUS ON PRAYER, REFLECTION, AND
GROWING IN OUR PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH GOD.
SO IMPORTANT.
I ASK ALL AMERICANS TO PRAY THAT
GOD WILL HEAL OUR NATION, TO
BRING COMFORT TO THOSE WHO ARE
GRIEVING, TO GIVE STRENGTH TO
THE DOCTORS, NURSES, AND
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, TO RESTORE
HEALTH TO THE SICK, AND TO RENEW
THE HOPE IN EVERY PERSON WHO IS
SUFFERING.
OUR NATION WILL COME THROUGH
LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
I THANK THE MANY FAMILIES WHO
HAVE PRAYED FOR ME AND FOR MY
FAMILY, AND YOUR PRAYERS ARE
FELT, I AM FOREVER GRATEFUL.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR GREAT
VICE PRESIDENT AND HIS WONDERFUL
WIFE, WHO WE ALL KNOW VERY WELL.
KAREN, FOR THE INCREDIBLE JOB
THEY DO, AND FOR THEIR SERVICE
NOT TO THE COUNTRY FOR
THEIR SERVICE TO GOD.
ALMOST 3,000 YEARS AGO, THE
PROPHET ISAIAH RODE THESE WORDS.
"DARKNESS COVERS THE EARTH, BUT
THE LORD RISES UPON YOU, AND HIS
GLORY APPEARS OVER YOU, FOR THE
LORD WILL BE YOUR EVERLASTING
LIGHT."
AS OUR NATION BATTLES THE
INVISIBLE ENEMY, WE REAFFIRM
THAT AMERICANS BELIEVE IN THE
POWER OF PRAYER.
WE GIVE THANKS FOR THE MAJESTY
OF CREATION, AND FOR THE GIFT OF
ETERNAL LIFE.
AND WE PLACE OUR TRUST IN THE
HANDS OF ALMIGHTY GOD.
I’D LIKE TO JUST WISH EVERYBODY
A VERY HAPPY EASTER.
WE ARE GOING TO BE CELEBRATING
THAT VERY, VERY SPECIAL DAY, AND
IT’S GOING TO BE, HOPEFULLY, A
VERY GOOD WEEKEND AND A VERY
PRODUCTIVE WEEKEND.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY IN OUR
COUNTRY AND BEYOND FOR ALL
THEY’VE HAD TO PUT UP WITH.
184 COUNTRIES, AS OF THIS
MORNING, ARE FIGHTING THIS
ENEMY.
WE PRAY FOR THEM ALL.
WITH THAT, I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE BISHOP HARRY JACKSON,
FROM MARYLAND.
A HIGHLY RESPECTED GENTLEMAN WHO
IS A MEMBER OF OUR FAITH AND A
PERSON THAT WE HAVE TREMENDOUS
RESPECT FOR.
BISHOP, PLEASE.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
FIRST OF ALL, LET ME SAY
THANK YOU FOR THE JOB YOU ARE
DOING.
YOU, AND THE VICE PRESIDENT, TO
PROTECT OUR NATION.
AND TO INCLUDE THE CHURCHES.
MANY CHURCHES WOULD HAVE HAD TO
CLOSE DOWN, HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
YOUR INSIGHTFUL LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH.
GOOD FRIDAY IS ONE OF THE
DARKEST DAYS IN THE CHRISTIAN
FAITH, IN THAT CHRIST STOOD IN
SUBSTITUTION FOR OUR SINS.
BUT THE RESURRECTION IS OUR
VICTORY.
IT PARALLELS WITH PASSOVER.
I’M GOING TO READ TWO VERSUS AND
PRAY ABOUT WHAT WE WANT TO HAVE
HAPPEN.
WE WANT THIS PLAGUE TO PASS
OVER.
WE WANT EVERYONE IN AMERICA TO
BE SAFE.
PSALM ONE 1105 SAYS, "HE BROUGHT
THEM OUT WITH SILVER AND GOLD,
AND THERE WAS NO EVIL AMONG HIS
TRIBE."
VERSE 39 GOES ON TO SAY, "HE
SPREAD A CLOUD FOR COVERING AND
FIRE TO GIVE LIGHT IN THE
NIGHT."
LET US PRAY.
LORD, LET THE DEATH ANGEL PASS
OVER.
LET THERE BE A MITIGATION OF
THIS PLAGUE, THIS DISEASE.
LET MEDICAL SCIENCE COME FORTH.
LORD, LET US COME OUT WITH A
DRIVING ECONOMY, THAT SILVER AND
GOLD SPOKEN OF IN THAT PASSAGE.
LET IT BE OUR PORTION.
AND THEN, GOD, AS WE FACE OTHER
CHALLENGES IN THE FUTURE, LORD,
COVER US WITH A CLOUD BY DAY AND
A FIRE BY NIGHT.
IN THIS GREAT LAND THAT WAS SET
UP TO GLORIFY YOUR NAME, WE WANT
TO COME AGAINST THE SPIRIT OF
DIVISION.
LORD, LET THIS BE A REALITY IN
US.
LET THERE BE A UNITING OF
AMERICA.
HEAL THE DIVIDE BETWEEN RACE,
CLASS, AND GENDER.
ONCE AGAIN, GIVE THIS GREAT MAN,
OUR PRESIDENT, AND GIVE THE
VICE PRESIDENT WISDOM BEYOND
THEIR NATURAL LIMITATIONS.
GIVE THEM INSIGHT SO THEY CAN
COVER US, LEAD US, AND BLESS US.
WE BLESS THEM AND AMERICA IN’S
NAME
HOPE IS ON THE WAY.
AMEN.
>> President Trump: THAT WAS A
GREAT HONOR.
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU ALL.
HAVE A GREAT GOOD FRIDAY, AND
WE’LL SEE YOU IN A LITTLE WHILE.
ALSO, IF I DON’T SEE YOU, HAVE A
GREAT EASTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT,
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO
CHURCHES?
SHOULD PASTORS HAVE EASTER
SERVICES?
>> President Trump: THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>> Reporter: COULD WE ASK YOU
AT THE BRIEFING PERHAPS?
OKAY, THANK YOU.